toll endlich geht die reise los
ich bin schon sehr auf berlin gespannt
warst du schon mal in berlin
[Musik]
nein du
ja aber das war vor 15 jahren
aber das war vor 15 jahren
es ist schon so lange her
ich will unbedingt zum brand burgert ohr
gehen
unbedingt zum brandenburger tor gehen
ich auch
ich möchte gerne ein fußballspiel im
berliner olympiastadion sehen
morgen spielt die hertha bsc berlin
gegen borussia dortmund
da bin ich dabei
ich habe jetzt aber hunger
kriegen wir etwas zu essen
ja ich glaube schon
bald kommt sicher etwas zu essen
guten tag
hätten sie gerne etwas zu essen und
trinken
ja gerne
haben sie ein schinken sandwich
haben wie ein
in sandwich
dazu hätte ich gerne noch eine coca cola
[Musik]
ich habe leider kein schinken sandwich
es bleiben noch käse und salami
sandwiches
was hätten sie gern
dann nehme ich gerne das salami sandwich
sehr gut vielen dank
hier bitteschön
ich hätte gern ein käses händler
ich hätte gern ein käse sandwich
hier bitteschön
wir sind schon am landen
bist du auch so aufgeregt wie ich
th zuerst müssen wir unser gepäck
abholen
[Musik]
zuerst müssen wir unser gepäck abholen
danach müssen wir die u bahn suchen
der u bahn werden wir zum hotel fahren
[Musik]
sehr gut das wird gar kein problem für
uns
wir sind schon bald bei der
gepäckausgabe
danach müssen wir keine passkontrolle
machen
die schweiz und deutschland sind im
schengen raum
deshalb gibt es keine passkontrollen
zeit gibt es keine passkontrollen
genau das ist richtig
das ist viel einfacher so
so müssen wir nicht lange warten
hoffentlich kommt unser gepäck bald
ich möchte ins zentrum gehen
ich muss
der unbedingt eine currywurst essen
heute unbedingt eine currywurst essen
ach das hört sich ja sooo lecker an
doch das hört sich ja sooo lecker an
ich bin dabei
und danach möchte ich noch einen
berliner krapfen essen
schau mal unser gepäck kommt
sehr gut
jetzt können wir noch unser geld
wechseln
jetzt können noch unser geld wechseln
gehen wir zum bahnhof
nach gehen wir zum bahnhof
guten tag
ich würde gerne 300 schweizer franken in
euro wechseln
guten tag sehr gerne
das ist kein problem
für 300 schweizer franken erhalten sie
260 euro
ist das in ordnung
dieser wechselkurs ist aber tief
dann wechseln nur 50 schweizer franken
dann wechseln wir nur 50 schweizer
franken
den rest können wir in der stadt
wechseln
der wechselkurs ist dort besser
ja ich bin einverstanden
okay das ist kein problem
für 50 schweizer franken kriegen sie 43
euro
vielen dank
hier können wir zwei tickets kaufen
[Musik]
für acht euro kommen wir beide in die
stadt
das ist sehr gut
so kommen wir schnell und günstig zum
hotel
wir müssen den nächsten zug nehmen
wir direkt zu unserem hotel
so kommen wir direkt zu unserem hotel
das ist toll
so kommen wir zum hotel
so kommen wir schnell zum hotel
bis zu unserem hotel haben wir 14
stationen
von dort aus sind es noch fünf minuten
zu fuß
ist super
es nicht anstrengend
so
wird es nicht anstrengend
aber auch nicht viel gepäck
wir haben aber auch nicht viel gepäck
now
hoffe nur dass es nicht regnet
ich hoffe nur dass es nicht regnet
ja das wäre nicht ideal
wir beim nächsten halt aussteigen
müssen beim nächsten halt aussteigen
bist du bereit
ja danke
abonniere den kanal der halo deutsch
schule
und aktiviere das kleine glöckchen
gib uns jetzt einen daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diese playlist um weitere
videos zu sehen